hey what's up a standard wiring here my
boy tomorrow who say no gonna years ago
it's a going well my friends for those
who don't know means more used to make
videos about video games on a different
website that we run ourselves now we
both work at gamespot you just started
over in the UK and while you're over
here III baybiie like 73 the electronic
triples on so we thought since you're in
town why not sit down and play the game
that everyone's talking about its home
improvisation not let your fan of
omelets love a good room look are you
fan of Swedish furniture creators I am
I've been known to be a connoisseur I
cute boots well this is basically ikea
the video and as we can see just like
IKEA products they've is going to form
and function essentially making whatever
you buy useless useless or the good look
at ya one or the other let's start with
form I'm the purple that'll do it here
you can play this with up to four people
mm-hmm circles yes and we're going with
two here cuz it's gonna be crazy enough
as it is we got basements we got dining
room stuff we got living room I say we
let's check out the living room tomorrow
yeah ways in her oh my gosh living stuff
oh look at this oh it's a board looks
like we're cool click on the Borg yes
give me that boo oh okay we got to
cooperatively make some so this is this
is just like one of those co-op style
games right away I'm just the whole
point of me is to just harass you while
you may not gonna make it yeah you could
just like whole can I like this behind
me and just pull there we go over here
that's great there's four mine their
eggs need to go Scout you exercise games
are we still be stuck now can i guess
it's where the coffers are basically
ruined the game for this head as all
Feng Shui knowledgeable people know this
goes right in the middle look now I have
to use this I pull out the other thing I
gotta pull out the legs yeah look I got
like whoa
what's there wherever is stuff is about
to get holes in it oh my god my whole
gun is useless how do I fly my whole gun
I think this is like a world record for
somebody trolling on a game like this
you didn't even wait till I got one leg
in that really think that's I know my
time with these games and interest is
limited so I'm just gonna skip to the
shoaling right at the stop oh my my
table over here has got two legs on its
I'm trying to drop this whole gun into
into the last of us you think you can do
it I can't do it i'm using the earth i
like this make your own phone to your
sis about you use an xbox 360 gamepad
you complete us on the mouse as well
look there's some lining up I've got
reckon I got this I got that you think
as you can see this is next-gen gaming I
know if you see the shadows there that
is next in gaming let's even come next
in physics oh my gosh take that square
enix keep your luminous engine that's
not about the ikea engine well you just
ruined my workspace here so I'm gonna
have to like clean all this up it's fine
i'll just put holes in anything then
we'll just stick it to the world i suck
i get my last leg i could find the
stupid leg I get stuck in the bottom of
this see if there's any knowledge in
these books nope Michael ikea money was
utterly useless oh is that a manual i
assume so okay look at this I'm just
like this is like vacuuming the living
room type action oh there we go got my
lying up there you wanna let it get away
from me but don't you dare pick the like
that look oh how nice alright this Bank
gotta put the last one and I've to
listen to look into a racing game
alright so for the triggers nice with
elevations and danya you can rotate it
with
yes he's got an ax to ative and I was
like Matt ones it's not quite Maxis but
its own I'm soon gonna keep your Harbor
it near it basically a line appears
again I might have watch it happen so
you do it give you another person
furniture it's kind of selfish point
isn't good he's kind of satisfying like
it like real ikea do you want the collar
neck or the funds and squashed this one
this type of one over that looks real
easy to make here you want to go for it
looks like a horrible swear word all
right you go for it I'm gonna give me
this the flower hearts gonna line the
re-ask in the crush everything whatever
let's put you over here for now there's
a lot of pieces here so the thing about
this game is right now it gets a bit
more complicated man owes the submitter
at some hitman one physics Hammond there
this this room is haunted by someone who
was obviously killed her constructing if
the couch probably some box landed on
their head I'm gay I think we can make
this more interesting by trying to
reconstruct his face the devil do I
don't know I'll just paint the white
right is any super glue in this toolbox
the rail is your wife there is a mallet
there's a glue gun isn't it yeah I don't
know if we've got the time fidelity
inclination well I'm worried about more
anything else that's gonna I can't Malik
things you think I can lock these off
the roof just hit them oh yeah look
they're not fixed a lot look at this
look at this are you charging jerk you
took about my table so pretty much
anything that might lead touches it's
like stores how really it is actually
just me only guys BAM oh yeah I'll do it
I nearly had this thing open the light
switch is this is like dog shows what is
actually a story hidden in the
environment you know is how the duck on
the far right is actually different from
the other two duck you think maybe Italy
duckling they stink you know maybe
behind that there is a hidden boss arena
like not as the number of somebody I can
pay to actually build this furniture for
me this is like Hideo Kojima's PT except
way more Swedish what's going on my
cursor just been out there on but I've
been revolving get you back no I'm not
I've been given the time out I'm sorry
man that sucks it sucks for you and I
think maybe if I back out we can we can
get you back in we should try to go into
a different room this happens but no I'm
staying on your back your back blowing
around as a table hovering in the corner
for some reason so one thing you got to
do if you're playing with the controller
is yet really have to plug out the mouse
you think is the mouse basically if you
touch anything it'll like start as a new
character devices by pause bike or the
corner look I'm yeah that's not girls I
go that's no good doing the corner at
least the vows lives another day I'm
gonna try to start pasting this thing
back together while you ruin me if it
was look this is gonna decide whether
this game is really worth your money oh
if it breaks on the catcher if it Eva
breaks if it lands on the couch safely
yes you buy this game ok if it bounces
off the couch you should buy this game
if it just shatters on the couch you
think that's unrealistic you not buy
this game ok guys whoever made this
that's games yeah that's games faucet
official verdict that's it mr. kevin van
are just giving it on the way so one of
my favorite things about this game is
you don't really have to piece it
together properly to win you just have
to piece it together so i'm gonna try
and like approximate this thing but the
slots probably aren't going to line up
too good as you can see already if you
angle this table properly looks like a
walrus you see
I do it now that's all I see now I want
to make a walrus it's just the walrus
out of sorts of it the function section
actually has a kind of a bunch of little
mini games are making stuff so maybe we
can get into that in a second you're a
literally this is exactly what it's like
it's like you moved to a new place you
invite your mate over to help you build
some furniture and it's just what
happens vaca bag no mate turns up a bit
high and just starts doing weird stuff
if you like my weight look at my way
stuff like it is like this piece of
modern table ours I'm creating he's
trying to wonder if it will try and
connect the two think of it you want
list think there's no giving me the
lines oh wait no I'm not doing that I'm
not doing that are you gonna don't you
dare don't you dare all you son of a
[ __ ] why is that my perfect table I've
got a perfect table I'm sure the
Europeans could come up with a function
for that off the embodiment of chaos at
least could put give a four legs don't
give it like a weird like gammy leg or
something she wants this money somewhere
else but okay okay it is I'll come and
get it ah this is some rich bozo would
buy this for like at least a million
that's the thing if you had this table
if you just made this table like if you
like the ikea version of this cost like
to quit but if you want this actual like
modern artist looking one it's probably
gonna cost you about the fitting granite
an art gallery
this last leg on so I want what are you
doing over there I'm getting this
cushion involved here they get the
Christian good stick on here we're
trying to hook the cushion into the hole
I need one more one more spot right one
more I'll be in there we in there maybe
the cushion is a super glue that they'll
hold it all together oh this is physics
happening here whoa I just going through
it whoa I think if you played this game
properly and actually cooperate instead
of just trying to put a create chaos it
would actually be quite satisfying what
it I reckon there's a there's a level of
like a therapeutic elements to it that
people could have of course like it's
way more fun Justin Wade crap that is
give me that at least let me stick the
last piece on because then we get
another one what where we go we go I
don't think I can go i'm talking like
I'm holding this in midair for you to
fix it sort of I can't even see if I
wonder what other things that are made
in like primary school this is like the
Crimson I doctor yeah here we go watch
watch i watch this right little put a
little hold on it watch hold it there
hold it there I did I did CDT craft
designers school cause a computer
college across design technology or
something like that and I bring this
home and be like that and look like me
and be like I'm so losing mass kindling
right now look I made it done I'm gonna
put it down wait to see what it looks
like a label it looks like kind of like
a like a lifting bench for Jim made by
someone who's not over what do you mean
what is it it's right there it's amazing
actually for some reason it's not given
us a new piece of furniture apparently
is not happy with the way we made that
IKEA has banned us from a dare they
let's check out a different room about
databases yeah this up is just like a
murder that's happened in there I need
to reconstruct gotta use a paint brush
and just clean it up oh look at ease oh
yes it's a Dodge I'm a dart what is this
that's the worst part is that they take
away the picture immediately so you
don't know what it is one of those kids
that what's a fancy chairs I fancy chair
I hope it's not something like the
piping system for this is this is not
enough you are getting good oh you can
stick a leg on I believe in you in there
yeah they go there you go hey day nah
well you can do one leg I believe in you
this is why i can never this is one of
my rooms over there got horrible
altering physics happening physics there
you go I don't know just per se yeah
press n we made a sweet chair flipping
through the ground want to do hast du
hast get some runs team up with you yeah
yeah I do it gon do it look at how a
chair in the background is just thinking
out having a good ol time we've just
made it like a zero energy machine it's
just not a chair that's some sort of yes
Oh may I think we [ __ ] up with it with
the legs that is not how you chair Oh du
hast du hast mace do you ask I just
gotta paint it and with that go for it I
just touch it I wonder if we can upgrade
this chair with the dual at the du hast
module good i got an achievement you
think we get is a Michelangelo I've been
that basically means you've just created
crap and now people are gonna act like
it's the greatest thing ever so as long
as that's what I think you can make a
hole on it so if I can just like drill a
hole here to husk watch this right to
the hole there you go there's a peg
actually that's not a hell of it's a peg
I need to make no it's a hundred percent
more comfortable film or gone
yeah you're your left butt cheek really
gonna hate this chair where is it the
content
yep yep I don't I stick this light on
top this chair can't actually stand I'm
actually holding you out really which
means it's the worst chair there you go
infinitely better goodness are you still
holding an operas and sometimes i'm
holding a sure yes our styling answer i
mean let me balance it out and yeah I'm
but I'm helping i'm doing counterweight
I can't figure this out there now leave
a go i bet it's time now no no okay
buddy I'll save you so she's drunk made
go hold on there cinder blocks over
there other actually you like luxury use
it to hold it up alright alright we're
doing waiting on you need to like
position it on this corner right here
maybe we can use the like the stairs as
well be the legs are an optical illusion
actually not era them as they turn and
then look away yeah alright your entire
world will turn do it all right yeah our
[ __ ] cinder blocks I'm sorry
sinem we're going to know a shitty need
not want any known i can get you another
one I later be all right I think if I
move this back it's a bit it's a bit huh
buddy poverty on but be honest if I move
this far enough so it just catches the
age you understand got it no not having
it yep one more one more if you wedge it
I think you can move it down here in
this area and let it fall forward vowel
and I got this let's pick up these in
the block you want to got a baseball
swing them out they're good I'll just
drop it like that I'll just drop a line
you try to hit when I midair oh [ __ ]
this is like what street by a pro touch
look like this is the hurricane kick the
hurricane kicks all off yoshinori ono
you need to add physics into this game
and he's like we look at the second
language 345 be here this is it's just
it's all right there you go nothing okay
let's get out of the basement this is
your let's get engaged all right you
know what actually the dining room will
leave for all that for all the folks you
want to pick up doing themselves let's
check out function yeah what's [ __ ]
on about I'm sure why we gotta do what
we gotta do are you undo the honors yep
pull it place your trophy up
I forgot to read there for a second
you've got a lovely trophy and it's okay
so we need to swap put it on display for
the world to see okay just put it there
you go my trophies weren't here I've it
this yeah I read that that's pretty good
nailed it and then now we nail this oh I
say what we do is we now let's table to
the war you think we can do that I don't
know that the or not there's no nail gun
is a lil don't to see that's it I like
it you're thinking outside the box yeah
actually can I just put it up here and
then we're gonna hold up for three
seconds as I work no that's not a great
place for the true i think it's a pretty
much a pretty red it's a good it's all
good place for the table yeah but it's a
good place I fit so my god oh my god
that is what I don't get how that work
no [ __ ] way no [ __ ] way your genius
two more you're an absolute genius I
know that's right oh I trophy
yeah really fight maybe she's right oh
tonsai oh yeah at least you later like
you make you play this game before no oh
oh you sort of did we get it maybe we
live on no way not bad something to play
a higher okay right oh my god we've
already put a higher than anyone look
every week we've always done it everyone
is seeing that trophy and then they're
saying why is it on the table floating
this guy let's try and deal yeah I like
the idea that you're supposed to like
put the table on the ground and they're
like you know make something higher
we've already we've subverted this game
in a way that developers never knew was
possible I'm gonna I'm gonna say the
developers might have known I was gonna
make a bunch of pegs all right right and
then I'll put this whatever you want
their triangle thing put whatever you
want madness with the pegs before stick
someone's expression the amiable by pigs
all right it's gonna nice look good
there's no deadline we've got to be
careful otherwise the I could use this
as like a rack so I'm not the falls off
see it's like it's like a passer perfect
see that well done like a protector
boundaries look at this we can stick
ones up on this okay
I want to [ __ ] put this in copper
veal is by far the most fun I've had
yeah forever making famous era
difficult making furniture I made the
same piece of furniture in three
countries like you I made the same
television stand in the contact Guinness
I'm sure they'll give you a record they
won't give a miracle to anything yeah
Dan reichert is a good example of there
you go look at this look at this because
you know we could do is I just put a
bunch of [ __ ] on top just lay it up
there yeah and then drop the trophy from
behind see what oh look at how you have
to get it we don't have to get it above
that we're already there you got out we
got our own the trophy it's already
there already there make we got this
it's already there
yeah we on killing this look at me look
at this perfect eSports being it'll she
would you go for gold sign us up if you
need inspecting champion look at this oh
man i was going to stick this while i'm
having a little look we can just pile up
on shirt we don't have to drill it in no
way what I've done oh no [ __ ]
devastating absolutely devastating home
improvisation two more it's add on Steam
early access for the low low price of
nine dollar ninety-nine cents and if
you're paying attention earlier on the
vase versus of the couch you'll know
where we should buy it so no yes sir
okay so I'd like sale of a skip back if
you're watching this after the first
five minutes for some reason tomorrow
pleasures Iver yep times i'll see you at
e3 yep let's let's stop the recording
but keep playing this game okay yeah
it's actually quite fun
you